a taco Tuesday but it's also National
Taco day and we are celebrating with El
Luchador and Mexican Kitchen and cantina
and joining us we have Chef Lorena tell
us thank you for being here thank you
for having me and I said I'm not just
saying this the minute you walk into
this room it smells incredible in here
so let's talk about it you guys have
some specials going on for taco Tuesday
and National Taco day yes correct we
have all the tacos at two dollars so we
have carnitas tacos tacos for the people
that don't like meat we have quinoa
tacos crispy quinoa tacos
and you said one of your favorite tacos
are the Carnitas right yes
it smells so good so let's make the
carnitas tacos and while you're prepping
really quickly you guys have two
locations Henderson and off of blue
diamond right yes correct and those
specials are going on all day and night
yes
all right so what are we topping the
carnitas with with the arbor salsa and
picolonians this is is very easy see I
like it and it smells delicious in
addition to the tacos I'm gonna take a
bite of that in a second you have some
guacamole you have some desserts you
guys have everything you could ever want
um we make everything every single day
is fresh you can see a rice truly
Hispanic Mexican rice so we have here
fresh guacamole refried beans and of
course the carnitas so but let me let me
make another Taco this is my favorite
one okay we're gonna keep it coming with
the tacos you guys have a daily happy
hour right yes and then you have over I
think 80 Tequilas is that right
so you can pair a taco with a delicious
Margarita or cup of tequila right and
you can finish it with the flan what is
this Taco that you made here this is the
adobo this Taco okay yes we use a
roasted salsa cilantro onions totally
different from Carnitas are amazing can
I try a buyer making it fresh or
something okay I'm going in for it be
honest oh I'm sure it's delicious if it
tastes anything like it smells it's
going to be incredible and just a quick
reminder again two dollar tacos you do
that every Taco Tuesday but you guys are
going big for National Taco day right
yes
that one is a little bit spicy on the
salsa take a little bite here we go
hmm oh my God
so where I am we're kicking off National
Taco day in the right way and I can't
talk this way to my mouth thank you so
much for being here thank you go
celebrate National Taco day Mercedes
I'll save you a bite